il vous dira qu'un pédophile n'ai jamais
tiré d'affaires que si on gratte le
vernis on va encore découvrir d'autres
choses
quesada il fait encore l'objet de cinq
plaintes qui sont déposées contre lui
certaines seront classées sans suite
peut-être peut-être pas peut-être que
les cinq seront suivis poursuivi feront
l'objet d'une ouverture d'information et
puis d'une suite judiciaire mais mais
visiblement christian quesada n'en n'a
pas fini avec la justice
c'est un point de vue tout à fait
personnel reste à savoir quel
comportement adoptera christian quesada
à sa sortie va-t-il quitter la france
pour se faire oublier
on se dit bonjour attendus dès 20h50
cette mise au jeu est ce que vous les
trouver at il demandé mais il n'a rien
compris mais là tu veux pas te faire
vacciner mais si j'ai jamais c'est à
dire oui pour demain il veut se faire
vacciner dans l'émission comme ça ce
sera fait très peur est inquiète pas
soyez rien à payer et rembourser les
cherry on dit avec non version gay
paparazzi on ne dira pas paradis qui a
planqué de nombreuses fois devant le
nouveau domicile de christian quesada et
bruno pomart anciens policiers du raid
qui a enquêté note bruno juste gilles
verdez pour les téléspectateurs
christian quesada a disparu mais qu'est
ce qui se passe en fait parce que il
il doit pointer dans sait comment ça se
passe alors il est choisi un contrôle un
suivi socio judiciaire très strict donc
il doit répondre à toutes les
convocations d'un juge d'application des
peines
il doit être disponible quand on le
visite et il doit prévenir de tout
changement de domicile et de tout
déplacement de plus de 15 jours
d'accord visiblement là andy va nous le
dire il a disparu sans laisser d'adressé
il avait donné une adresse
le lendemain sa sortie de prison à bourg
en bresse hilton une adresse qu'on a il
s'installe et puis il disparaît il parle
donc ça c'est pas prise il est considéré
comme un fugitif et oui il est en cavale
il a disparu corps et biens
à la manière de xavier dupont de
ligonnès n'ont pas pour les méfaits
commis mais pour le la cavale la
disparition il s'est volatilisé
s'accroît incroyable alors on dit merci
d'être là déjà sans donner la date
exacte pour quel point il était dans
quel camp vous ne présentez pas très
loin de l'espagne vers la frontière
ah ouais d'accord dès qu'il est sorti de
prison il avait déjà une planque il
avait il a changé de domicile à la
à sa sortie de prison il s'est
enregistré au niveau des services
sociaux alors vous vous lavez la sa
sortie de prison qu'il avait une envie
était pas d'accord mirsad ne savait
quand elle est sortie d'accord et je
pense que ça a été protégé sa sortie de
prison il était protégé
comment vous allez vendre et sa trace
grâce à un informateur qui travaille
dans un service qui m'a donné sa
nouvelle adresse et qui venait de tomber
donc enfin conclut il est sorti le 25 et
la nouvelle adresse est sorti le 25 mars
est d'accord donc et vous là vous l'avez
vu physiquement
non j'ai vu son frère d'accord y
habitent dans la même rue que lui
d'accord
donc comment il a fait pour s'organiser
ce avec la femme qui avait annoncé sa
famille qui a dû faire les réservations
de d'appartements à laquelle elle
qu'elle loue quelle était la frontière
de l'espagne pas très loin mais d'accord
pour penser qu'il a choisi cet endroit
opposé qu'il préparait sa cavale
je sais pas s'il ya ou trois jours on a
eu trois policiers qui sont arrivés de
la bac à 9h30 le matin et ses trois
policiers de la bac 1 ces noms des
policiers au bac
nous on était dans une voiture vitres
teintées ils sont sortis on s'est dit
bon on s'est fait contre on va se faire
contrôler que mon associé alors on a les
photos
voilà voilà ouais là ils sortent de chez
lui en fin de compte
alors donc là il ou christian quesada
alors là y'a pas christian ce qui est ça
la salle si l'arrivée c'est des trois
policiers de la bac vocation sur une
convocation
donc là on est jeudi 31 mars il est 9h30
du matin
on n'est pas très loin de la frontière
espagnole et ses trois policiers se
rendre pour mettre une convocation ou
pour l'entendre
qu'est ce que c'est une convocation
parce qu'il s'est pas présenté à son
service au service socio judiciaire ou
est ce que il a des casseroles au cul et
qu'il ya un ou deux à faire encore et le
juge a demandé à la police voit la
police mais justement de disqualifier ce
que vous dites en dit pas ce que c'est
ça
si c'est pas présenter au contrôle
judiciaire si vous êtes l'avait plus
minces si vous êtes pinky vous avez
purgé votre tête vous présentait donc à
votre avis il pense qu'il y avait
d'autres choses qui allaient sortir donc
c'est pour ça qu'il a préféré partir en
cavale
je sais par et ce qu'il a fait une
ligonnès ou pas une de ligonnès on
sépare et c'est incroyable
voilà l'incroyable ce garçon juste il
peut essayer voir d'où des
rebondissements dans la sphère parce
qu'on sait qu'il y avait d'autres
plaintes qui est bien reposé contrefaçon
à césar ce n'ont pas été jugés donc
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas du tout écrit
sans quesada il est effectivement passé
dans cette région nous par élimination
n'a enquêté il est plus évidemment à
hauteville dans sa maison dans l'ain
puisque plus personne ne veut le voir
aux deux villes a été jeté un par le
voisinage et cessons ces affaires est
coupé du déménagement il n'est pas à
l'étranger
il rêvait d'aller en thaïlande au japon
il n'y ait pas pourquoi parce que
restrictions sanitaires parce qu'il est
interdit de voyager par sa condamnation
et on a enquêté aussi à béziers dans
l'hérault parce qu'il avait acheté un
petit studio à béziers suite à sa
victoire aux 12 coups de midi pour 30000
euros
on a vérifié il n'est pas là bas non
plus donc personne ne sait où et
d'actuels grèce nous avons besoin de
dire doko téléspecteurs aujourd'hui
christian cachât wright en cavale il est
en cavale
et effectivement ça peut être parce
qu'il ne s'est pas présenté aux
policiers mais ça peut aussi être parce
qu'il ya un nouveau rebondissement dans
la sphère on sait qu'il ya énormément de
plaintes qui ont été déposées les urnes
est bon on va pas donner la ville mais
il est pas loin de béziers dans une
grande ville française
effectivement est ce qu'il y ait encore
là il y ait plus diront qu est-ce que
vous avez planqué devant chez lui vous
l'avez jamais vu on a planqué plus de
trois semaines
ouais voilà tout simplement et à la
sortie de ces trois policiers donc
sortes ont mis une attestation une
convocation dans la boîte aux lettres et
sont sortis à trois numéros de son
adresse et on était chez son frère aîné
pareil déposer aussi une convocation est
lui par contre habite là-bas après on a
planqué le frère en a planqué toutes les
deux côtés ont planqué des deux côtés
pour essayer de faire des photos de
christian et gloria les relous de la
chaîne qui disent ces propos n'engagent
que vous cessez s'est déroulé pour la
michel avec son rôle ou si oui lions pas
vous l'avions évoqué que il a changé de
look
voilà bien s'inverser les cheveux que
vous aviez dit il ressemble à robinson
crusoé oise et ses codétenus il a
complètement changé doute donc on a
l'impression d'une préparation
effectivement la grande question qui se
pose c'est est ce que les policiers de
la bac agissait il ya une chance sur
deux sur commission rogatoire d'un juge
d'instruction pour une nouvelle affaire
on va on a d'autres infos bruno pomart
vous avez enquêté sur donc donc question
quesada c'est fou ça il sort d'où il
sort de prison
il doit pointer et il se présente pas il
s'est pas présentée pendant combien de
temps on sait pas exactement combien de
temps mais le suivi les traces très lent
ps3 en prison la première interrogation
c'est il faut savoir qu'elle était
incarcérée eux non il devait en prendre
cinq ans
là il faudrait poser la question à la
justice encore une fois la justice est
quand même des comptes à rendre sur ce
sujet là quand on connais quand même les
faits reprochés à cet individu
on se demande comment il a pu être
relâchée alors on l'a volé deux ans il a
été 2e vingt deux années de deux ans bon
pourquoi on l'a relâché ça c'est une
vaste interrogation est-ce que c'est par
rapport au corps vide je ne sais quoi
mais fait quand on voit leur le marais
supporter son âge ont des bonnes
conduites à peine un mois le palmarès de
ce personnage pas possible deuxième
information intéressante et et notre
papa m'a dit et bien plus au courant
parfois que que certains policiers c'est
que les policiers les secteurs dans
laquelle il se trouve est censé se
trouver du personnel sont pas tous au
courant de ce qui se trame réellement
dans le secteur où il est ils étaient
motivés ça c'est d'une véritable
interrogation
encore une fois on se demande ce que la
justice a pu bien décider sur son dos
alors quid de ces enfants me dit clément
guérin
il est adroit de les vois pas ce que
c'est ça il va vouloir les deux enfants
il a tout à fait le droit de les voir
mais on ne sait pas si effectivement ils
sont au courant si sa famille proche et
ce qu'on a dit c'est pour chaussures et
coûte peut-être ravi mais sur un avis il
a le poteau tout l'environnement bien
évidemment il ne s'est soucié dormez
bien sûr le frère les parents évidemment
qui vous assurer que la première
réaction je dirais de ce type le
personnage ou l'autre c'est
effectivement la famille l'environnement
direct mais je comprends pas ils peuvent
pas faire une perquisition chez sa
famille et c'est vrai que ce soit clair
pour les téléspectateurs
question quesada qui se présente pas
donc de ce qu'il doit pointer c'est quoi
tous les soirs où tout laisse non il
doit répondre aux convocations
régulièrement il est pasteur et placer
le reich qui est ce qu il a raté des
convocations
cyril on n'a pas ces traitements
nécessaires précise n'ont alors pas donc
il est par la loi et mine de rien non
mais il recherchait de se présenter ou
pas au commissariat ça dépend des
procédures qui sont en cours mais il ya
un délégué de justice également qui est
là pour constater que la personne est
sous contrôle judiciaire et si le
respectent pas les règles de base
effectivement elle est quasiment assurée
rien qu'à resserera nouveau quai d info
guy novès c'est celle de la perquisition
pour saisir son matériel on sait que à
plusieurs reprises dans la sphère et les
affaires christian quesada tout a
démarré par une perquisition on a saisi
ses disques durs des ordinateurs ces
clés usb ses téléphones portables parce
que je rappelle qu'il a été condamné
pour détention d'imagés
pédopornographiques dont qui peuvent
aussi être août on est chez lui pour une
nouvelle affaire pour aller chercher
éventuellement du matériel informatique
à l'entreprise will question côté il a
gagné beaucoup d'argent qu'il était sûr
télévision il n'y a pas une façon de
tracer qu'une carte bleue aller voir
savons que c'est sa famille oui on dit
ladhuie la russe a dû se renseigner il a
gagné six cent mille euros je les ai or
donc il y avait huit cent mille euros en
tout 200 mille euros de gains et de
cadeaux il ya six ans milo et après
quand on voit de ligonnès qui paraît
soi-disant n'avait pas beaucoup de sous
et qu'il arrive à partir de plus la
subir on lit se dissimuler d'un société
française est compliqué de se planquer
yeux bah ouais mais bon quand m et 1,14
non mais on peut pas mettre les
enquêteurs 24 heures sur 24
même sur un cas comme ça il faut savoir
quand même qu'il ya un paquet de deux
problématiques à régler d'un sommet et
safari sur écoute pas score n'avait que
24 heures sur 24
cyril surveiller un mec comme ça 24
heures sur 24 savent quelque chose n'est
pas paradis il le faisait à 3 mais nous
ne sommes
c'est un effectif considérable donc les
policiers peuvent pas surveiller un gars
comme ça 24 heures sur 24 ce n'est pas
possible
vous pensez qu'il avait prévu de
disparaître est-ce qu'il a tout tout
organisé pendant ces deux ans de prison
il te dit jean mouawad a juste un truc
que je comprends pas il joue et je leur
posais la question parce que là je vous
dis ouais elle est fou votre histoire
franchement oui les mecs question
quesada il a purgé sa peine oui d'après
la justice voilà elle a pris cette
décision au nom n'a pas revenir là
dessus miceli la donne en mille il a
purgé sa peine il a pêché deux ans de
prison
il est sorti les mecs s'il a envie de
disparaître et qu'on le voit plus il
fait ce qu'il veut non c'est non mais si
le droit non mais même s'il sait pas
s'il n'a pas eu 6 il n'a pas eu de
manquement et qu'il sait pas on n'a pas
de preuve qui s'est pas présentée à un
commissariat quelques voiliers qu'elle
n'a pas envie de voir votre gun ou plus
doit la mienne non mais il doit être
localisable en permanence ses 800
quesada le suivi est très sinueux droit
disparaît dans la nature
là il a effacé ses réseaux sociaux tout
instagram on a l'impression d'une fuite
organisée
quesada n'est pas libre il ya de suivi
de 5,1 libre le socio judiciaire sans
détour j'aimerais qu'on dise pour des
spectateurs
il doit pointer 6 et s'il n'y a pas de
manquement s'il n'a pas besoin d'eux
s'il est voté on n'a rien à dire c'est
tout qu'est-ce qui arrive et on s'était
quand la police arrive chez lui à
l'adresse qu'il a donné aux instances
officielles et onudi ya quelques jours
donne n'est pas libre de 10 par an il
est banni arrivant sûr il n'a pas là où
vous devriez
et quoi encore mais moi j'avais une
question il a parce qu'il a une
obligation d'être sur un lieu précis 24
heures sur 24 où il doit être logés
comme on dit ici rires ça veut dire
qu'il peut partir à 200 km et revenir la
quitter à savoir les restrictions qui a
il est il doit avoir sûrement des
restrictions de terminer on dit je sais
que vous avez parlé avec les policiers
voilà qu'est ce qui vous ont dit on n'a
pas parlé avec les policiers en fin de
compte moi j'étais en train de faire les
photos que vous avez vu des policiers
qui sortait et mon associé des sorties
s'est mis devant l'immeuble à fumer une
cigarette avec le masque quoi enlever le
mas qui fait à fumer sa cigarette et
entendit commence à nous casser les
couilles quesada tout simplement il ya
une petite en fin de compte il y avait
c'est un petit immeuble il ya douze 12
propriétaires qui sont locataires qui
sont dans cet immeuble
beaucoup de retraités dedans donc toute
la journée on voyait le le passage des
gens qui promenait leur chien qu'ils
allaient faire leurs courses qu'ils
allaient travailler et quand les
policiers sont rentrés on a vu qu'ils
étaient perdus
il y avait un monde alors il y avait un
une boîte aux lettres où il n'y avait
pas de nom du tout et un interphone où
il n'y avait pas de nom est cité perdue
ils ont sonné sonné sonné et après ils
ont sonné et une petite dame nouveau
traité est descendu leur a fait voir cet
immeuble la cet appartement là et voilà
mais ils n'ont pas retrouvé
non ils ont participé ils sont de likes
de là ils sont sortis pour aller chez
son frère aux 43 d'accord donc là
aujourd'hui je vous explique moi c'est
ça que j'aimerais savoir c'est vraiment
la dernière question et c'est la
question la plus importante aujourd'hui
est ce qu'on a fait ou est ce qu'on a
convoqué christian quesada est ce qu'on
a dit peut-être à sa famille est ce
qu'on a fait savoir à sa famille que
christian quesada devait se présenter
aux autorités quand donc parce que si
dans ce cas là on l'a fait savoir qu'une
question quesada l'oci et qui s'est pas
présenté la wii c'est enfin j'étais
journaliste mais à l'envers
vous avez ikoko m'a dit notre ami
il y avait trois policiers de la bac qui
sont venus lui apporter une convocation
la convocation ils ont trouvé personne
ils sont allés voir le frère ou quelques
membres de la famille pour la remettre
et pour dire attention il faut que
monsieur quesada se rendre dans cette
course là pour vous bon moment qui
connaissait bien la voilà à la police a
oui mais s'agit-il
c'est un fugitif aussi dirais que c'est
un fugitif mais sachez aujourd'hui est
ce qu'on peut avoir
voilà un truc si vous voyez que
christian quesada ça pourrait le faire
oui je ne le font pas
écoutez c'est la justice qui décidera ce
qu'il faut c'est mon papa je vous dis la
vérité
l'histoire allait pas clair celui
bernède excusez moi vous savez
spécialiste des faits divers est là vous
êtes du spécialiste mais je vous le dis
un point que je le verrai je vous dis la
vérité
on a on n'a pas d'info sur le truc si le
mec il est sur wii les fugitifs où il
est paré sidi bouzid il faut faire un
avis de recherche mais c'est la police
on est en mesure d'assurer que christian
quesada a disparu c'est au jury quesada
a disparu alors on fait quoi
les policiers sont en train de le
rechercher ils ont déposé cette
suggestion cette série les épreuves
finales mais bien sûr et christian
quesada en cavale dit disparaissant
c'est énorme comme avril n'a pas le
droit cyril oui mais pourquoi n'y a pas
d'avis de recherche
ben non pas du tout sabatier le chercher
et vous savez même s'il sait que
l'action l'endroit où ça se trouve cette
affaire-là
moi j'ai activé mon réseau de policiers
certains policiers savaient même pas
qu'il est dans le secteur dans lequel il
doit peut-être l'actuellement donc c'est
pour vous dire on peut savoir des sondés
sur la grille avec excusez moi c'est
vénus excusez moi de vous dire ça qui
est de rien faire c'est ça la frère
c'est pas mesrine
non je déconne et les gens sont quand
même vous avez raison c'est bien dit
finalement le droit que de faire oublier
il a totalement droit de supprimer ces
réseaux sociaux huawei l amérique et
c'est même moi pourquoi les policiers
vont chez lui les policiers n'ont pas
aller chez lui après sa mise en
libération ça veut bien dire qu'il ya un
problème on n'a plus qu'à dire on dit
voyez un nouveau rebondissement dans la
ferme et christian quesada je veux dire
que c'est pas mes rides mais c'est comme
quelqu'un d'extrêmement intelligent donc
s'il veut qu'on perd sa trace il sera
inutile est évidemment passée carte
bleue il n'y a plus beaucoup d'argent
parce qu'il a énormément dépensé il a
offert beaucoup de ces cadeaux pour
faire oublier à son voisinage et c'est
son frère qui gère beaucoup sa sortie il
compte beaucoup sur son frère laurent
son frère son père
pourquoi pourquoi on n'interroge pas son
frère ces choses évidentes et par son
plein mais il a bien prémédité sont
effectivement ces jets de se signaler il
ya il est saoul mais c'est aussi un
judiciaire pendant cinq ans et obligés
de signaler la wii les vous avez parlé
sur ce sujet parce qu'on à 10h05
moi je vous dis la vérité
effectivement avec un pasteur à paris
cinq minutes de savoir si c'est pas en
décalage warfare oui bon c'est sûr mais
on l'a déjà dit ça oui on n'est ce pas
marre film est en cavale si c'est un
fugitif
oui c'est donc un loup solitaire malgré
tout d'être mou solitaire on dit souvent
que ça coûte très cher organisé on a
peut-être des complices a forcément sa
famille forcément est sur écoute
est-ce qu'on va pas justement avoir une
sorte de traçabilité justement de ces
dépenses mais c'est encore une fois
c'est là dessus ex client n'a qu'à qui
peut le retrouver s'il est ou va t on